[Music]
you're basically the big breakout star
of the show what do you think is the
biggest misconception that people have
about you I think that you know people
saying that I used sex or my sexuality
to like jet Roses is just stupid that's
it honestly the whipped-cream thing was
kind of a spur of the moment like oh
this is funny you know people took such
offense that like calm down it's really
not that's really not um I will admit I
did look a little bit more promiscuous
than I thought it would but I'm sorry I
don't know I'm human I just thought it
was cute and funny and holy that's a lot
take a lot a lot do you feel that you
were [ __ ] shamed by the other women I
think that maybe I was a little bit [ __ ]
shamed but come on I mean if there's no
sexual attraction then just don't even
bother to all you women out there take
that advice so I mean for those people
who did give you backlash online or any
of the haters what's your message to
them my message them is that listen I'm
sorry that I did something to make you
that upset but I can't make the world
happy troublemaker is there anything
that's looking back you would have done
differently no I mean I don't have any
regrets from this season um me
[Music]
you